namo tassa bhagavato harahato samma sambuddhassa namo tassa bhagavato harahato samma sambuddhassa namo tassa bhagavato harahato samma sambuddhassa
So just to continue the words that the Buddha used in dependent origination.
So we went through the first parts which are basically to do with how we enter into every moment with this ignorance, this not knowing.
and it creates these sankaras which are the conditions that we end up manufacturing through this misunderstanding.
And there's the given, there's consciousness which is that point of cognition and the body-mind complex and those two remember work on each other, the Buddha said they're like two sheaves
of hey leaning against each other, the one can't arise without the other.
And then we have what the body and mind, what the constituents are, the nāma, the salayata, the six senses, and with that we make contact.
This contact has an object, it has a sense base, and it has that consciousness we're talking about.
And then we give it a tone color, a feeling color, whether it's pleasant, unpleasant, or neutral.
So that's what you enter each moment with, as it were.
That's your given, that's your viparka, that's the product of past action.
Now, this is where the ignorance now strikes again, as it were, underneath the whole problem and produces a certain relationship to what we find as pleasant and unpleasant, and that's your tanha.
So this tanha is translated as craving, which is sometimes a little bit too strong for these little desires we have.
But we include things like addictions and compulsive behaviors in this tanha.
And some people translate it as lack, a sense of lack, like you've got a big hole, you've got to fill it up.
A thirst, another translation you'll come across.
But the usual one you get is craving.
And what that is telling us again is just what our relationship to something is.
And the relationship, remember, is always based on this wrong understanding of seeking happiness in the wrong place, perfect happiness.
So that's your tanha.
And that should become pretty straightforward when you meditate, because when something comes up, you'll see your reaction.
And remember, it's not always craving in a sense of wanting something.
It's not wanting something, too.
So you get resistance and indulgence, resistance and indulgence.
So that's your hate-love dichotomy of life, you see.
And it's at this point that the duality begins to hurt.
We live in a dual world in the sense that it's a multi-complex world, but as soon as we enter into it with this duality of wanting-not-wanting, then it becomes a very unpleasant place for us.
In meditation we're able to see that quite clearly.
But the next step, upadana, is the point where we lose it, where we actually drop into that desire.
That's the becoming of a self, that's the self, the I.
And the Buddha actually calls the Khanda, remember, the five Khandas that we talked about, you know, which are the body, perceptions, feelings, these conditional volitions and consciousness, he called them the Upadana Khanda, the grasping Khanda.
and the thing about this Upadana is that once you enter into it the I, the self becomes and that's the point of suffering actually the tanha in meditation we can see is just a sort of a desire in the heart wanting and not wanting but so long as it's an object so long as we're quite distinct from it it's not actually dukkha, it's not suffering
the suffering comes with the self with the identity with that wanting it's a very lovely little subtle point to sort of grasp and once the I has gone in there I mean I have actually seen it this sucking into an object but it's very difficult to stop then the impulsion the pushing into that wanting a power
While it's tanha, while it's just desire, it only remains potential.
Nothing's happened.
It's just a movement in the mind of resisting or indulging.
But nothing's actually happened.
but as soon as the I gets in there then as I say it's very difficult to stop the next one which is Bhāva the becoming it's at this point that the will comes in and that's your cetana and the Buddha says your cetana your will which is a power is your kamma meaning your action not your kamma in the common ordinary sense of that word that's used in English meaning your comeuppance
Kamma here is an act.
And the act is the becoming of a self again.
So bhava you see.
So every time we fall into the I and do something out of the position of an I, we're becoming.
And that of course is the world of samsara.
So these three words the Buddha tries to capture that whole business of how we create suffering and how we continue to create suffering and the process that we go through.
And you'll see that it's the opposite of language.
Language normally say, I want, I scream.
But actually, I scream, want, I.
And as soon as you get I, get.
And that's it.
That sequence, you see, to see that sequence is to see more and more clearly where the escape is.
if there was no desire before the I, then the escape would be really exceedingly difficult because you'd have to catch this identity extraordinarily quickly but because between the vedana, what we like and dislike, and the I, there lies this potential that we call tanha, the craving
the wanting the not wanting it gives us that if we can see that it gives us that gap in our in our experience
And that's really where we can begin to change ourselves, because when we see that tanha, this craving, call it that, is unwholesome, we can let it pass away, we can let it pass away, we can let it drop away.
And in so doing, remember, it's undermining a habit of craving.
And that is what our sankāras are, our conditional, volitional, volitional conditioning.
It's like these huge circles, they're little circles within this greater circle of dependent origination, all bits feeding off each other.
And there are times when we can see that the desires that come up are actually wholesome.
Okay, they might have a touch of I in it, but the point is that they're wholesome.
And by actually, you know, by putting our will into that, then obviously that's changing our personality.
See?
so those three little links are where the Buddha explains how we carry on creating these sankhāras, these volitional conditionings based on this ground of not knowing, of ignorance, of delusion
so not only in meditation but in daily life you see as soon as you see that I want come up that wanting come up if we can just stop at that moment you see and just catch the craving before we do something that's where we've got the power to change ourselves every time we miss it with either reinforcing an old conditioning which may be unwholesome or
or starting a new one, which may also be wholesome.
So it's a case of bringing this type of mindfulness into virtually everything we do.
And in this way, you know, we just, we slowly change ourselves.
And I think one of the things we come across is the power of these old desires, you know.
They're very, very, they're much, very, very strong, much stronger than we think they are.
So, that's it.
I hope my words have been of some assistance.
May you be fully liberated from all your tanha, upadana, and bhava, sooner rather than later.